Hi everybody's, it's time for?
Pop quiz.
Whoo!
(audience cheers)
(bell dings)
Okay, where is Fiona Channer?
Fiona, oh, over there.
Hi, come over here!
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
Hi, give a 360?
Yes, 360, look at the white pants.
Chic with the boots, yes!
(audience cheers)
Cute, ooh (giggles).
You know you like the reveal?
Yes (giggles).
Fiona, you are so head to toe
beautiful and chic.
Oh, thank you, Drew.
If you want, correctly answer three questions
about today's show,
you could win a $1000.
What do you think?
I'm excited.
(piggy bank chings)
Okay, okay.
All right, let's try this.
All right, you ask the first question.
All right, first up the highest tea party on record
was just held on top of which mountain?
We all know the Brits love their high tea, right?
But it was an American who just managed to host
the highest high tea on record.
Listen to this, CNN Travel reports,
Andrew Hughes hosted a tea party
at the very tippy top of Mount Everest.
Mount Everest.
(bell dings)
That's right, that's right.
(audience cheers)
That's one question right.
You gotta get two more correct.
Drew is stretching.
She's stressed out.
I'll stretch with you.
I get really nervous and excited.
(Ross giggles)
Okay, second question.
What am I doing at Ross's wedding?
You guys know Drew Barrymore
is my flower girl at the wedding.
I'm his flower girl.
Yay!
Ooh, you're the flower girl.
Yes!
(bell dings)
(audience claps)
All right, you got two rights.
I do, I get nervous.
(audience cheers)
Ha, you're so funny.
All right, Rossi.
Okay, third question for a $1000.
How long does the shrimp dish
Drew and Pilar cooked take to make?
(Fiona inhales)
It's coming to me.
We have a new segment we're running
and it's seven minutes to make,
which I love.
Uh huh?
Was it seven minutes?
Yeah!
(bell dings)
(upbeat music)
(piggy bank chings)
Chest bump, mm.
(audience cheers)
Yes, yeah, yes, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
You won a $1000
and thank you for making it happen.
'Cause I get really upset
when it doesn't work out.
So I'm glad for you
and thank you from me and my heart.
Congrats.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪